the seven princes of hell
is an idea we mentioned when we
discussed lucifer
it's not necessarily one that is
mentioned explicitly in scripture
but it is an interesting idea that many
scholars have attempted to explain
in the last 600 years today we'll take a
look at some of these ideas
mostly focusing on the classification of
demons
by peter binsfeld which borrows heavily
from the idea of the seven
deadly sins as we are on the topic of
hellish
nightmares browsing the internet
shouldn't be a nightmare experience for
anyone
thanks to today's sponsor expressvpn you
can browse the internet
safely without any privacy concerns
with so many of us now working from home
keeping sensitive information and data
private is as important as it's ever
been
with expressvpn's encryption standard
your data and browsing history
is safe from isps the government
hackers and even expressvpn themselves
vpns have a multitude of other uses
such as being able to receive discounts
when shopping online
based on your location i personally use
them to change my location
giving me access to shows and movies
that would have been
otherwise unavailable on websites such
as
youtube netflix hulu and many more
for example i can change my location to
canada and have access to shows such as
vikings that would normally be
unavailable one thing i've noticed with
expressvpn in particular is that your
broadband speed is never slowed down
or hindered which isn't the case for
other vpn services
find out how you can get three months
for free today by using my custom link
expressvpn
mythology the link will also be in the
description of this video
so don't miss out
peter binsfeld was a german bishop and
religious scholar born in germany
in 1540 or 1545 depending on varying
sources
as a child peter was gifted enough to be
sent to rome to study
when he returned he became a prominent
figure in many
anti-protestant campaigns
what he was most well known for was the
part he played in the witch trials of
trier that took place in 1581
until 1593. binsfeld wrote an
influential piece
titled of the confessions of warlocks
and witches
which contained the alleged confessions
of these individuals
that had been obtained through torture
and therefore according to him should be
believed and trusted
this is important because at the time
peter was considered a
rather intelligent man an expert in
religion and its supernatural
elements in 1589 amongst the chaos of
these witch trials he published a list
of demons
that he believed to be the princes or
lords of
hell according to binsfeld the seven
deadly sins were much
more than just deadly vices he believed
each one was in fact a demon
so who are these demons
the first of these is lucifer who
represented
the sin of pride the original
and most serious of the seven deadly
sins
as there is an entire video devoted to
lucifer i won't go into too much detail
here but in this regard binsfeld is
referring to lucifer the fallen
angel his overwhelming pride led to him
believing that he could rule heaven
and so he was cast out and demonized
when his rebellion was unsuccessful
the ever-present reminder of the dangers
when one allows
pride to overcome them some consider
lucifer to be the ruler of the seven
princes
these accounts often believe lucifer and
satan
are the same individual other
classifications who don't agree
see satan as the figurehead of hell an
entity
separate from lucifer they even
sometimes replace
lucifer with another fallen angel figure
such as azzazo
the second demon binsfeld mentions is
mammon
whose name roughly translates to mean
money
and i'm sure you've guessed he is the
embodiment of our next sin
greed in scripture mammon isn't
necessarily a physical
being more so a concept surrounding
money wealth and greed over time this
began to change
and it was during the middle ages mammon
became more than just a concept
he was personified as the demon of greed
in numerous pieces of art and literature
and thus some scholars began to classify
him as one of the princes of
hell who would enslave those who were
driven by
greed and the accumulation of wealth
at times mammon can be confused with
beelzebub
and though they both can be seen as
demons of greed
greed and gluttony aren't necessarily
the same thing
the third prince of hell is asmodius who
represented
the sin of lust most of what we know
about asmodeus comes from the book of
tobit
as well as some other talmudic stories
such as the construction of the temple
of solomon many saw his role as
spreading lust
through the land from common people to
kings and queens
nobody was safe in the book of tobit he
fell in love with a woman named sarah
and prevented her from marrying anyone
else
he also killed seven of her husbands the
night of their wedding just before they
could consummate the marriage
the eighth husband tobias was lucky
enough not to suffer a
similar fate following advice given to
him by the archangel raphael he was able
to repel the demon
he placed a fish's heart and liver over
some burning coals
and when asmodeus paid them a visit that
evening the smell
caused him to flee where he would later
be bound by raphael
in the talmud and the testament of
solomon asmodeus has numerous encounters
with solomon
and there is a passage that mentions him
marrying lilith
and taking her as his demon queen his
appearance can vary
but most of the time we see a part-man
part animal hybrid the cabala explains
this as him being a
cambian a half-human half-demon
offspring his mother a succubus and his
father king david
[Music]
the fourth demon prince according to
binsfeld
was leviathan which represented
the sin of envy this one may seem a
little
odd as when most people think of the
leviathan
they think of an enormous sea monster
not exactly something you'd assume would
be found in hell
it has dozens of interpretations and
meanings across
numerous religions but this association
with
envy and the princes of hell that
binsfield speaks of
is a christian concept the italian
philosopher and catholic
priest thomas aquinas described it as a
demon responsible for punishing those
guilty of envy by swallowing them whole
leviathan was also often seen as
representing the gates of
hell in anglo-saxon art the entrance to
hell
was seen as the gaping mouth of a
monster
known as the hellmouth or the jaws of
hell
with the leviathan being seen as all
sorts of creatures from a giant sea
serpent
to a large whale or even a crocodile
it's likely the creature's gaping more
was enough to influence this
anglo-saxon motif
the fifth demon prince is beelzebub
the lord of gluttony another name you
may also see
is the lord of flies or the lord of
fliers
which refers to his ability to well
fly beelzebub is a figure who can be
traced back through
numerous civilizations and religions in
the testament of solomon he is a fallen
angel
often associated with lucifer
he doesn't necessarily have a particular
domain
he just behaves in a generic demon-esque
manner
causing men to worship demons and turn
on each other
succumb to lust jealousy and murder
just an all-round troublemaker the dutch
demonologist
johann veer saw him as the chief
lieutenant to lucifer
and integral to a successful revolt
against the devil
john milton also shared this view in
paradise lost beelzebub
is a fallen angel who along with
asheroth
is second only to lucifer in terms of
hierarchy
why binsfeld considers him the lord of
gluttony
is hard to say as others equated him to
false gods
pride and envy
demon prince number six is undoubtedly
the most well-known
satan the lord of wrath
as this is peter binsfeld's
classification we can assume
when he says satan he's referring to the
christian interpretation
in the early modern period from around
the 16th century onwards
just after the middle ages from around
1480
onwards the hysteria around the idea of
witches began to spiral out of control
in some european countries france and
binsfeld's native germany were two of
the most notorious examples
heinrich kramer and jacob springer's
malius maleficaram was published in 1487
and this explained that all sorcery was
rooted in the work of satan
and thus we see satan's association with
warlocks and witches
in the middle ages satan was always
depicted as pitiful and repulsive
with no real power but now with the fear
of
witchcraft on the rise naturally satan
would become a demon that people feared
so much so that the church
turned its attention away from other
religions
the focus was now on satan the simple
belief in him was thought to lead
christians astray
[Music]
our final demon prince is belfagore
the lord of sloth binsfeld saw him as
the chief of
laziness and though he does have a point
there is
more to his character you wouldn't be
wrong to argue that
he is better suited as the prince of
manipulation
and deceit belfagor takes many
forms choosing whichever one he feels
will convince his victims into doing his
bidding he convinces seduces and
manipulates humans into creating
ingenious inventions that will make them
rich a whisper or a nudge in a certain
direction that leads to amazing
discoveries
but when these are complete the wealth
and esteem is snatched away by belfagore
he may not be the most imposing or
terrifying demon
but belfagore is about as cunning and
deceitful as they come
there are many different classifications
of demons by many different scholars and
we've only just looked at one
if you'd like to do some further reading
and see how they differ
then you can simply search the
classification of demons and you'll find
a host of varying ideas you can examine
as always i've been your host
mythology and fiction explained
[Music]
you